Rita Dove and tidal well professor of
English I guess
you know when I read this sounds really
weird but when I was about ten or eleven
I stumbled across the Iliad at home my
father had bought the great books of the
Western world and one of the first books
there was the Iliad I had no idea what
it was but it was a very long thing and
I thought this is the beginning of
literature so I'm going to read this and
I understood probably about half of it
but it was fascinating it was an
incredibly tense and interesting story
and once I got into the whole way that
the the poems worked it read like a like
a swashbuckling mystery in a way so that
made me feel like gosh this is exciting
I'd like to do that too
the one that I remember I wrote poems
before this but the one that I
considered the first real poem was about
that time - it was an Easter poem it's
in school we were supposed to write a
ride or paint or do something artistic
for Easter so I wrote this poem called
the rabbit with the droopy ear and I
remember it because when I began writing
the poem I had no idea how it was going
to end I just had this idea of a rabbit
the Easter Bunny
who had one ear that you know drooped
down and he was distressed so I kept
writing and it rhymed and all that and
it was actually the rhyme itself that
helped me solve the problem of the
rabbit with the droopy year so the end
of the poem it goes hip hip hooray let's
toast him a cup for now both ears were
hanging up he hangs himself from a tree
in his ears hanging straight and
everybody's cheering and I was just I
don't know it was very exciting to to
find that nd I actually had to read it
aloud in class you know that was another
thing those were the days when you did
these things in class but now people
show their paintings if they had
something from for Easter and I had to
read my poem aloud and and people liked
it the kids liked my friends so that was
an instant success story
it hasn't totally changed it is changed
in the sense that that in some extent I
know let's say that the goal is not to
come to some kind of neat solution as
that did but but it hasn't changed in
the sense that at some level I'm never
quite sure how the poem is going to
resolve itself and that I'm always in
some way surprised I make a discovery in
a poem where I write it by now that
means more accessing the subconscious
and the fact that if I begin writing a
poem on that means I'm intrigued in some
way by whatever it's about and that if
I'm not trying to find something new and
pushing that envelope in the poem I
can't expect my reader to be
particularly excited about it either
it's different every time and in fact
years ago there was an I did do
something like that for a magazine where
it where a journalist actually followed
me around and we tried it but but it's
slightly different every time my
inspiration comes from everywhere just
walking down street just and I never
know where it's gonna come from so I
keep a notebook with me at all times and
the only criteria for anything making it
into that notebook is if it stops me in
my tracks for even an instant if it
catches my eye or my ear you know and
and I just write it down that means that
there are recipes in there you know
there are words and sometimes there's a
character description or sometimes it's
a line and after that point though what
happens is kind of odd I tend to I work
in fragments in the sense that I'm not
going to sit down and say the first line
is this and now I'm gonna just write my
way through it
I let the poem it's like piecing it
together like a pot so I might have a
line that I might write down on the
middle of a page and I still write
things down with a pen on paper I go to
the computer when when it gets too messy
and use it like an elaborate typewriter
because I print it out and then I mess
it up again but when I do get down sit
down to write in my room with my study
and I try to write at a certain time
every night I'm a night person my best
times are midnight to 6:00 actually I'll
leave through my notebooks and if
something catches my eye and I feel like
I want to transfer it from the notebook
to the page I do and then comes this
very strange process which is difficult
to describe and that write until I get
stuck or I can't go any further or I'm
boring myself or whatever and then I
might go to another poem I might go to
another folder where there are other
drafts of poems in various stages of
completion
and the only way I have for keeping
track of all this fragmentary stuff is
by color and I have different colored
folders red folders yellow so I might go
into my study let's say one evening and
say I feel like three blue folder today
and I'll pick up the blue folder and see
what's in there so it's something that
I've kind of worked at over the years
but the colors are only because I didn't
want to put anything I didn't wanna file
anything you know in a straight you know
I think if you put something in a file
that says war poems or love pumps but
you already restrict the way in which
the poem might move if I put it in blue
it could be sad blue it could be happy
blue it could be peaceful blue but my
mood at the moment when I'm about to
work on that poem once will will tell me
where I want to go so it's an odd
process but I do do lots of revisions
and I love to revise so 3040 revisions
is not unusual at this stage I do most
of my revisions by myself until I reach
a point where I either need to give it
lots of time because time is a great
reviser to you know just months of
putting it aside or I will show it a lot
of times I'll show it to my husband who
is a novelist and as a prose writer he
has a totally different take on things
so he comes out in a different way
I yearn for those old days you know from
graduate school right you go into a
workshop and people would give you all
these ideas and you take it away from
you
but at this point that just doesn't it's
not in the card so
I think it's both I think that that you
certainly don't have to be ages and
think you know and and travel the world
to write a poem in fact sometimes
traveling the world is a way of not
writing a poem but it's the quality of
experience it's being able to to
experience something and when you begin
to write about it be able to apply the
tools that you need for writing you know
a mastery of the language and a way of
piecing together the language I guess
that those two factors have to come
together so you do need to be to work at
it but you also have to be able to know
when to when to take the experience as
it happened when to tweak it a little
bit what part of the experience is gonna
move somebody else in what part is
really your own private moment
so I've seen homes written by very young
people which are absolutely stunning and
of course we have examples look bawd
lair and leader wrote one was in his
teens these are amazing poem so he
obviously didn't have a wealth of
experience or age or anything like that
and I've seen poems which of course
could only have been written by someone
who was older and had lived certain you
know stages of life have gone through
certain stages like but as a combination
of the two really is
you know i-i've always felt that that
the poems are written which have
historical context are hopefully not
just simply plucking something our
history's a little great let's write
about that in every case what has
happened is that I've become fascinated
or haunted by something and couldn't
shake it as an african-american as a
woman I think that I've been sensitized
to the way in which history privileges
the white male and the way in which
certain aspects of history the things
that we are taught in school the things
that are handed down never never enter
the picture though they might have been
very important anyone can tell you that
at the risk of oversimplifying a and
whether you have complexes or whether
you need to prove yourself or all that
kind of stuff and yet the mother in a
traditional family who has raised Chuck
never makes it in the history books I
mean India so so those kinds of things
have always get a today's put it that
way and and I'm always reminded when I
when I see someone Napoleon's stalks
through the battlefields and I think
yeah but how do you get that way you
know how this guy become who he was so
that's that's the predisposition I had I
think as a writer as a person who wanted
to create poetry it's one of the things
that has always been one of my the
things I carry along with me each time
is different for instance in this new
book which is tells the story of a black
a mixed-race violinist George
bridgetower who grew up in 18th and 19th
century Europe
I came upon him because I was watching a
movie immortal beloved and there was a
scene in which Beethoven walks by a
group of musicians and there's this
black violin and so I'm like what I've
heard of color by casting because it's a
bit strange and so I looked him up and
the I didn't intend to write poems I
about it I just wanted to know more
about him and I kept reading in the more
read the more I realized the only way I
was going to get him out of my head was
to get into his and start write about so
in each case it's been something like
that
I think it's going to be a mix of things
when I find very interesting well first
of all poetry of all the forms of
literature I think is the most suited
for the digital age and for the shorter
attention spans and all of that it it
Twitter's very easily some lyric poems
and it's very easy to zip a poem to
someone so that's that's one of the
things that is wonderful about poetry in
the digital age I think that it's going
to be a mix between people who will
really only need to to see a book on a
page and those who will only want to
hear her on the stage or want to hear
them here the oil work what's
interesting about the digital age is
because of all of the ways in which we
have of transporting moving images now
and making it very portable the oral
aspect of poetry is coming back and the
poetry began as an oil discipline and we
had the printing press and then it
became gradually something which began
to lose a little bit of its musicality
because now we could read it so all of
the rhymed poems which you know all the
formal poems which certainly began as a
way of helping us remember a poem as an
aid to memory if it rhymed that wasn't
necessary anymore we moved away from
that now we have spoken word wine is
coming back in so it's absolutely
fascinating to me I think it's going to
change a little bit more become a little
bit more musical and we'll have a whole
range of things but it's an exciting
time
my first advice would be to read read
read it which sounds interesting coming
in a digital age but it's so much easier
to listen to a poem than it is to sit
down and actually read it and to hear it
in your head and that's something that
that every poet or aspiring poet needs
to be able to do anything to hear it in
their head what I wish someone had told
me hmm I wish someone had told me that
my stories are really mine to tell in
other words anything that I think is
important or that that has moved me has
the ability to move somebody else it it
was a long process too
for me and I think for many young poets
to be able to realize that even the
smallest the most domestic experience
can move someone else it doesn't have to
be about the Trojan War you know it
doesn't have to be the Iliad it doesn't
it doesn't have to be something that
again here we get to history that that
makes it to the front page of the news
but we live our lives in detail all of
us we walk down the street we breathe we
hear things we try to transcribe it in
generalities and the details are what
make us come alive and I wish someone
had said that just at the beginning so I
wouldn't have felt so discouraged when I
began writing and thinking who would
want to hear the stories of a young
black girl you know growing up in the
Midwest you know that's not interesting
I have to live in Paris no you don't
I'm not thinking of my audience which
does not mean that I'm doing it for
myself I'm thinking at the very
beginning when I begin writing a poem I
try not to think of the audience or
anyone at all except for trying to get
at the very center of what's driving
that poem why why in a way it's like
analyzing myself why did I even sit down
to write this why is it even interesting
what is it that drives this thing that
means xs/s I think the that means going
down into the very deepest psychological
moments things that can frighten and
scare you and and I think that to think
of an audience at that point would
actually drive those thoughts away but
and during the process of revision in
what happens is that I'm thinking about
the language and how I can use the
language which is my tool to convey
whatever this experience / emotion is so
that if anyone else sits down to read it
they can also feel it so it's beyond
just saying talking about describing
something it's also using words which
help to shape the emotion so that if
it's supposed to be something very
hectic or a frantic moment then the
words probably would be shorter and
clipped and you know things like that
during that revision process it becomes
less and less a private matter and bore
more something for an anonymous audience
I don't try to imagine an audience in
the sense of at that stage I don't try
to imagine an audience in the sense of
well these are all educated people you
know from the ages of eighteen to forty
you know five
I just think of there are someone out
there who might want to read this if
they read this well that I want to get
them to feel the same thing
that I'm feeling and that's my audience
but that in the end I'm thinking only of
them and I'm not there
it would be wonderful if we were
striving for toward a post-racial
literature and certainly the election of
Obama is a big step on the way I think
that we shouldn't get complacent and
they go gosh now we're post-racial we
are not we haven't had the conversations
we need to have about race and and
privilege and all of that stuff we're
starting so or on our way but one of the
things that I've always dreamed of is to
have a post-racial literature you waste
so much energy and good talent either
trying to insist upon your presence
which is certainly what happened in the
Black Arts Movement in the 60s for
instance and you also waste a lot of
energy then gee I lost my thought you
think
well you waste a lot of energy insisting
upon your presence but then you also can
waste a lot of energy explaining things
explaining things which are specific to
your to certain racial culture which if
you think about it in terms of the
mainstream we don't mind looking things
up if we don't understand them but we
kind of expect to be clued in on various
things that happen in in the culture one
of the things that I've always found
frustrating are the little reference
points that I might have to explain in a
poem that I wouldn't have to explain if
it were and it if if it were a
mainstream detail for instance I know
exactly how a white woman would do her
hair every morning I know the washing
and the blow-drying and all of that kind
of stuff but so that if I see that in a
poem if that were to occur in the poem
then I would have no problem with it
whereas for me to even to get up and and
and to explain getting up and rushing
and how to do my hair it would require
all sorts of glosses you know I'd have
to say well yes there's the this the
hair pomade and there's the this and and
and so my hope is that in a in a
post-racial culture all these kinds of
details we will just assume that we can
figure them out or we will assume that
that it's something as we read them that
will we'll have to to look up instead of
demanding that our writers give us some
gloss right in the middle of a poem I
think we're on our way
it's so funny when I was poet laureate
when I be when I was named poet laureate
I went down to Washington a little bit
beforehand to meet the assistant and
meet the librarian of Congress and all
that and to to kind of acclimate myself
and I did ask what my duties were the
only official duties are to sponsor a
reading series of the Library of
Congress twice a month and make sure
that these so that was fun to be able to
invite poets from all over the world
actually to come to read and to read for
the archives that was wonderful duty the
other duty was to advise the library in
Congress the librarian of Congress and
also and this was a funny one to promote
poetry in any way that I see fit I said
what does that mean to promote poetry I
said well what's the budget because
you're gonna promote me but and I got a
kind of a blank stare so I thought okay
this means that you make it up as you go
along what else does you know I'm an
artist I could create and I decided to
just do things and figured they would
stop me if they didn't have enough money
which was a probably good way to go
about it because they did find money for
various things but what was interesting
it's not it's sort of like being Miss
America or poetry and that as a as the
poet laureate you have an immediate
cachet and you have some you have status
people seem you have some kind of
complicity some kind of public stage
and I thought of myself as being more
like a lightning rod people would say oh
there's a poet laureate let's ask her or
let's tell her what to do and I got so
many letters right from the beginning
from people all over this country's
telling me what I should do and some of
them were really good ideas so and I
couldn't implement all of them at the
time I was there in the two years I was
there the one thing that I found very
very helpful was to remember that many
people are very frightened of poetry and
as poet laureate I had a chance to
travel around to just inject poetry into
everyday life whenever I could and so I
visited great school kids or the Naval
Academy I mean all sorts of places where
where you thought you know didn't know
they liked poetry or where poetry was
absolutely necessary
so each poet laureate decides kind of
what how they want to use that public
arena and I decided to to try to just be
there in people's faces when everything
they turned around to make poetry
something that was all around us I went
on Sesame Street for instance and and
yeah it was really fun the other thing
that happens with quote the poet
laureate ship is that when you are when
I was in Washington there was an
opportunity to inject poetry into the
government and though the port lawyer
does not have to write official poems
for anything there were many occasions
when I would be asked to say a few words
which is of course a kind of a euphemism
for do you have a poem well there's
always a poem you can always find a poem
for almost any human situation so I
didn't write poems source it for
specific events but I could look and see
if I had a poem which would fit and that
because I think that it's always
important it's important if
if there's a celebration for some bill
being passed it's nice to have a poem
that remind us all of the human element
and the human effort that went behind it
so that was that was important
the penguin anthology of 20 20th century
American poetry is it's a garganta cigar
can show and project and basically I'm
trying to make sense poetically of the
20th century in America so it starts
really right there with Edgar Arlington
Robinson and it goes up until anything
published year 2000 I'm trying so what
the difference in this anthology is
instead of just a poem here um there are
two poems like this person trying to
give a sense of of major poets who then
influenced other poets as well so there
we may be quite a few poems by say let's
choose someone William Carlos Williams
and then show how he influenced all
sorts of other poets who may have a few
other not as many poems in the anthology
what makes a classic poem I think that
when a poem can move
readers across generations and of course
it's specific class or race then it
becomes truly classic I mean in other
words if the poem is so moving that even
if you have no experience in that
particular setting be it 1920s harlem
let's say you still are so moved that
that that you can put yourself in that
position that means that the writer has
managed to go beyond the the personal
and and and touch the humanity in all of
us and it's been it's really a blast to
read it because I realized how that this
does hold true for the truly great poems
oh gosh no there's not a specific poem
there there it changes it changes
depending on the on the um what I'm
working with where I'm at at the moment
but there are I mean they're just poems
that are just so amazing to me and I and
if I name one that I'd of course lose
another but but it it goes in and out I
think that can you think I can't name a
specific one lines flowed through my
head there's a very beautiful German
poem by Goethe which I often say to
myself because it's like a little prayer
and uh but it's also totally
untranslatable I've never been able to
to translate it and it's humbling
because you realize that we need
translators please please please we need
our translators otherwise we'll never
have any of these poles we would never
know who how bottle air moves us or
anything like that but you also realize
how much gets lost
how necessarily poetry is sold bonded to
the to the language in which it is
composed that it's you you're always
going to lose something and I find that
very humbling um so yeah but it's a
wonderful permanent rhymes but it rhymes
in odd ways Eva Ella Gibson yes truth
and olive Epson spirits do come and how
barton or by the who was throughout
that's it you can hear the rhymes and
basically transfer it says over all the
mountains tranquility rests
in all of the tips of the trees and
that's VIP phone which is a great little
border all the tops of the trees you can
you can hardly feel a breath wait just
wait
soon you too will rest and it's just
it's because of the rise it makes and
there's such a calm home and it's just
in certain words are totally
untranslatable like VIP phone which does
mean tips of the trees but that doesn't
sound very good in English but it's it
almost walks you to sleep and I just
find it an incredibly amazing poem for
its tightness and yet
let me think what could I do a lot of
I'll read one
let I'll be the short one and but I have
to give you a little gloss for it in
this poem this is for my new book sonata
melodica which tells the story of George
bridgetower mulatto violinist from the
18th and 19th centuries in this poem he
was a prodigy he's a little boy 10 years
old in England playing his violin in
front of all of the music lovers of
London and his father is sent back a
sent away from London the Prince of
Wales says I'll take care of the little
boy and so you have this little boy who
is has the best job in the world for a
musician but at the same time has no
family and in this poem the prince has
ordered him to go into his room in to
change into British clothing the
undressing first the sash peacock blue
silk unfurling round and round until I'm
the India ink dotting a cold British eye
now I can bend to peel off my shoes try
to hook the tasseled tips into the
Emerald sails of my satin pantaloons
farewell sir monkey jacket monkey red
adieu shirt tart and bright as the
lemons the Prince once let me touch
goodbye Lakeside meadow goodbye
hummingbird throat no more games I am to
become a proper British gentleman cuffed
and buckled with breeches in a fine
cravat but how my tossed bed glows while
I I am a smudge a quenched wick a twig
shrouded in snow